finally An Early Access game that's
worth your time and money it's called
besiege baby and chances are you already
know about it but if not here's a quick
little rundown on what this $7 Alpha
game is all about you build death
machines to conquer the world here's the
world currently with only one condent to
play on yes there will be other condens
opening down the road but it's really
just hard to hate on this because the
core gameplay is all here continents
come with objective based zones pass one
zone move on to the next zone four for
instance the mo on this one is to
destroy this stupid windmill the
challenge a stone wall with archers is
protecting it you guessed it it's time
to crack open those creative juices I
present to you the Trojan Horse only
this wooden Steed isn't packing soldiers
but a cannon under its neck here we go
engage all right no sweat let's add some
braces to the neck and lose a little bit
of that ear weight and
fire and wait for the fire let's wait
for that let's do it again
fire hi ho
silver
get all right all right we're there
light them up baby and that's no I'll
take it next Zone let's try to change it
up give it up for the puncher not too
shabby toss on some flamethrowers wheel
blades and spiked
Knuckles all right scrap that let's
trash it let's let them come to us here
we have the death box strong metal on
the outside spiked death on the inside
with a side of
flame all right that worked out but I
know a few zones up ahead will require
this metal block to move so let's
strengthen this idea tripling the size
and adding multiple hidden weapons do
look slick but it forces you to slow
down gameplay time but the main problem
with this hunk of metal is that it
cannot steer around bombs so let's
forget driving all together the sieg's
newest update brings you balloons we're
taken to the skies
baby yep the balloon flying house from
Pixar's Up it was the first thing that
came to mind only this house isn't just
pack and a chubby boy scout but four
cannons and a bomb Oh look The Sheep are
following me
cute booah wall of archers meet
Cannon and then how about that
payload granted the lift off doesn't
always work out sometimes the balloons
pop as they float up the bomb donates a
little too early or oddly enough flaming
shrapnel would find its way to bring
this house down regardless of how many
times I let Russell die this has been my
most successful creation yet again
besiege is a bargain in my book $7 on
Steam and it's already one of my
favorites this year and I'll leave you
with this little Montage I put together
in honor of
Russell h on
boys oh this
makes